hello it's very nice to meet you and
congratulations Hello nice to meet you
as well thank you so I kind of wanted to
do like a behind the scenes career
overview kind of question to start here
because it can be like a small miracle
to get a film off the ground or to book
your next gig and you had an interesting
Journey because I was reading that
Alaska Land got rejected from all these
film festivals but then eventually you
get clemency but in the case of till
you're coming hot off the heels of a
very widely acclaimed feature film so
what was the experience like getting
this off the ground versus clemency
giving given your feature film your
first feature film experience
night and day I had a feeling I mean
one's an independent film Till's my
first Studio film you know in some ways
it was night and day and in other ways
it's the same like the Artistry and the
approach to the craft was still the same
for me
um the the the the you know the systems
around that craft are very different
um and so uh it was a great learning
experience for me you know clemency took
several years
several years to um for me to find
financing and it was a much much much
much much smaller budget film
um you know and it was just it was just
you know I I'm I I'm an artist I'm a
filmmaker and so it was really just
about the work I I didn't even I wasn't
expecting it I wasn't expecting clemency
to even make it to Sundance let alone
win like I just I was like I'm an artist
that's just what I'm focusing on and
then after clemency I was thrust into
the business of this craft that I've
been really honing for the last however
many years or half my life and so
um making till was a very was was craft
wise the same experience
um but everything else that came around
with it knowing that it was going to be
released and distributed you know
because when you make an independent
film you're just like oh yeah let's keep
fingers crossed
and so there was something special about
knowing that this film is going to be
seen
um and and and so yeah and I I had the
most extraordinary experience making it
I mean it was
when I tell some of my director friends
they're like wow that is a rare one
because I Had Creative autonomy and the
producers were like we believe in your
artistic vision and want you to tell the
story the way you want to tell it and so
did the studio you know they believed in
my artistic vision and as an as an
artist especially a black woman to have
that kind of to be given that kind of
creative autonomy and that that have
that kind of belief in my Artistry was
incredible smart people around you it
paid off for them quite well the film is
exceptional to kind of to kind of build
on the idea of this movie being seen and
I know this might be a little bit of an
odd question to ask at this point in the
film's run but I am also in the business
of talking things through and
manifesting so that's where this
question comes from but I am curious
what some of your personal takeaways
were from the award season uh campaign
for clemency and maybe how that's
impacting how you're looking at that
with till now because of course it's not
about getting statues or anything like
that but I mean need to be honest I'm
still a little hung up on the fact that
clemency seemed very deserving to me and
it didn't break into the Academy Award
nominations
I mean listen considering that I was
surprised clemency
screened at Sunday it's like I was I I
what was what I laugh about to this day
is you know when I when I was in
pre-production for clemency
I didn't know what an agent was I didn't
know what a manager would I was like I'm
an artist I'm just gonna focus on my
crap you know and so all that other
stuff I was like guys I I just wasn't I
wasn't even I literally was not thinking
about it
you know and so I you know listen
I I I'm really proud of clemency and I
and I'm Alfred gave an extraordinary
performance and you know um and and and
nothing can take away from that you know
and so
um and I move with that same kind of
energy with till you know but it's it's
great to have the support system of a
studio who's going to make sure the film
is out there and seen and received and
I'm also so incredibly proud of till and
all of the performances are phenomenal
Danielle especially is extraordinary
um and Jalen and John Douglas and
everybody is phenomenal and I'm proud of
the craft work that was done as well
from all the Departments and and so um
you know it's it's I hope everybody sees
it and I get really excited because
there's an infrastructure around till to
ensure that as many people as possible
see the film for what it's worth I will
do the necessary blabbing to help that
along thank you I mean it I mean it
going back to the very start of you
getting involved here I was watching
another interview you did when and you
said that you joined the project three
years ago and then you kind of needed to
catch up on all the research that had
been done meeting certain people
visiting certain locations things like
that what would you say is the biggest
difference between how you envisioned
the film turning out when you first you
know signed on the dotted line signed
onto the project and then how you
envisioned it turning out after you had
done all that personal prep for yourself
and you hit set
you know the vision didn't change too
much you know I I I came in with
such clarity about the perspective in
which I wanted to tell the story the
kind of visual language that I wanted to
create and that visual language you know
gets revised and tweaked along the way
but I was really I was pretty clear and
consistent about my my my narrative and
directorial intentions with the film and
I'm and
I I am really a very focused filmmaker
and
um and I'm I just have such great
clarity Within Myself about the overall
vision and you know to maintain that
Vision through the process is a miracle
in itself but I I'm really really proud
of the fact that that Vision was able to
be for the most part maintained and
that's largely because I was surrounded
by people who really believed in that
vision and provided as much support for
me to make sure I preserve that Vision
as much as possible okay so with that in
mind I'm curious if you encountered this
on set but even with all the prep work
you wind up doing and the clarity in
Your Vision in that sense is there any
particular scene that all the prep and
all the planning in the world never
could have gotten you to the point that
you did in the final film where you were
only able to achieve that kind of level
of magic in a scene when you're on set
working with your actors in the thick of
it oh that's the that see that's part of
the journey that is so beautiful it's
like I come so meticulously prepared so
I can throw everything out the out of
the way I I get so clear about what my
vision and intentions are so when
everything goes wrong I can do a plan F
that still is tied to the larger vision
and intentions so I will say may needs
testimony
the plan was
have eight or nine shots there are eight
or nine that that was the
the the what was in the film that was
the first thing first shot that we shot
after the first take
I'm like
[Laughter]
damn the crew gave Daniella Standing
Ovation because
and then we did a second take my
cinematographer and I look at each other
like
another show shot like this is it and
what I and so the I knew that on an
emotional level it was important that
visually I communicate the the we I stay
with Mamie's emotional Journey
throughout that testimony because she
goes through such a journey and that we
keep the pressure on her visually so
that was always a part of the vision I
thought that I walked into that scene
the first day of shooting it thinking I
needed these eight or nine shots to
communicate that Vision By the time
Danielle did that first and second take
I said oh this can also accomplish that
idea that Vision that I had but in a
different way and so I just had to make
adjustments in terms of Framing and
composition so we can I can make sure
that we understand the world that exists
beyond that frame you know with the
hands and the ring and the photo
um and and that kind of magic you just
don't plan you know you and and I I I'm
so open to that and that could that's
one of the many reasons why I get
excited about working with an actor like
Danielle is because you put her in front
of this camera and you just it just
opens up the possibilities for what you
can do you know the the you know the
long take of Alfrey near the end of
clemency where we hold on her that
wasn't planned either you know but what
was so but Alfrey and I through our prep
work we were so clear about what
Bernadine's emotional Journey was in
that scene
I thought we were going to capture that
emotional journey in a different way we
go on set
and I'm thinking after having spent you
know several days or a couple weeks
shooting with Alfrey at that time and
seeing what she can do in terms of
holding a screen I go to set that day we
shoot the ending of clemency and it's
like you know what Alfrey I have an idea
I'm just gonna stay on your face
all of those emotional beats we talked
about in this scene
be present to them
I'm not I'm just gonna stay with you I
didn't tell her how long we were gonna
do I didn't tell her if we were gonna
move I just said just be present and
that was one take that was one and it
was magical it's like those are the and
I felt that kind of magic when we did
the long when we did Mimi's testimony
you can't plan it but you just have to
be you have to be ready to receive it if
it's story appropriate in the future
keep that tactic in your back pop Pocket
because you you definitely wind up with
two exceptional uh single shots in both
cases oh I have so many more questions
but I need to let you go you have a
movie to celebrate and lots of promoting
to do and I will be doing it myself
because until is phenomenal and I can't
wait to talk about it quite a bit for
the next couple of months thank you so
much you take care